يصور كبار مستشاري البيت الأبيض
رحلة الرئيس بايدن الأولى إلى
الشرق الأوسط باعتبارها لحظة حاسمة
لإعادة الانخراط أو لتعزيز دور الولايات المتحدة
في منطقة ذات أهمية استراتيجية
من العالم ، وهو أمر أصبح
أكثر حدة على مدار
الأشهر العديدة الماضية  في أعقاب
الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا ، أصبحت الآن رحلة من ثلاث
محطات متجهة إلى إسرائيل والضفة الغربية
والمملكة العربية السعودية ، وفي حين
سيتم بالتأكيد فحص كل جانب من جوانب الرحلة
مع التركيز على
الاستقرار الإقليمي على الاستقرار الاقتصادي حتى على
مستوى عالمي محتمل.  أزمة الغذاء
ليس هناك شك في أن جميع الأنظار
ستتدرب في الغالب على Jedha عندما
يصل الرئيس إلى المملكة العربية السعودية وهو بلد
أشار إلى مملكة
أشار إليها على أنها شيء أراد أن
يجعل دولة منبوذة في عام 2019 عندما كان يخوض
حملة انتخابية لمنصب الرئيس.  في
أعقاب مقتل الصحفي جمال
خاشقجي قال الآن جيك سوليفان
مستشار الأمن القومي بالبيت الأبيض إن
الرئيس لا يندم.  هذه
الملاحظات لم يتراجع عنها ولكن هناك
حقيقة إستراتيجية
ومصلحة إستراتيجية في هذه المرحلة بالنسبة
للولايات المتحدة.
البحث عن السلام في مكان
مثل اليمن ، لذلك نحاول القيام
بأشياء متعددة في وقت واحد
على طول عدد من المسارات المختلفة
وكما قلت قبل التوجه الأساسي
والغرض من سياستنا فيما يتعلق
بالمملكة العربية السعودية هو إعادة تقويم
العلاقة ولكن  لا تمزقها ، لقد
ظللنا صادقين مع ذلك منذ
بداية هذه الإدارة ، حيث أوضح سوليفان أن
حقوق الإنسان ستكون
شيئًا يطرحه الرئيس ، لكن
حقائق هذه اللحظة التي
أصبحت واضحة تمامًا ، ما
عليك سوى النظر إلى أسعار الغاز  محطة الوقود المحلية الخاصة بك
والتي تؤكد على جزء كبير
من الزيارة إلى المملكة العربية السعودية حيث
ستكون أسعار الغاز لأمن الطاقة
شيئًا يطرحه المسؤولون الأمريكيون  ستكون
القضية الوحيدة التي يطرحونها مع السعودية ،
لكن السعودية هي أكبر لاعب في
أوبك بالإضافة إلى أنها مهمة بشكل واضح
لإمدادات النفط العالمية وقد أوضح المسؤولون الأمريكيون
أنهم سيطلبون المزيد من الإمدادات
ويعتقدون أن السعودية لديها القدرة
على فعل ذلك تمامًا.  في اجتماع الرئيس
مع العائلة المالكة السعودية ،
سيجتمع مع الملك سلمان ، وسيحضر ولي
العهد محمد بن سلمان
ذلك الاجتماع الثنائي
سواء كان الاثنان سيتصافحان
أم لا ، سواء كانت هناك صور
ملتقطة بشكل جيد أم لا ، وفقًا لسوليفان هو
لا يزال سؤال مفتوحا
فيل ماتينجلي CNN البيت الأبيض